hello the internet i'm gav in this video
we'll be revisiting the classic
mints in the old diet soda experiment
that we all know and love but with a
twist
this video is sponsored by mio it's a
liquid water enhancer
they've sponsored us in the past we're
very happy to have them back we'll be
using the mio to color the liquid
in our experiments and here's the twist
i was mentioning before
the phantom is mounted to a robotic
motion control arm so we should be able
to get
some epic looking shots okay you have to
pardon the rubbish bags on it we don't
want to get it wet
unlike other motion control arms this
one is capable of moving incredibly
quickly
you might want a duck
that is terrifying why don't we start
off with a nice simple static shot
for this experiment it's a good idea to
use diet soda because the aspartame in
that
gives it a much bigger reaction i'll
start by adding some watermelon so along
with the bold flavor of mio
also get some nice color this should
give our foam a lovely shade of red
okay you've joined me at my lovely pool
before we use the robot to do
crazy moves i want to test our little
rig here it's basically a nail that's
holding in a stack of
mints and when i pull them out we should
get a nice reaction
three two one
[Music]
thank you
okay for our next montage i want to film
a single mint falling in but in order to
do that i need a way to precisely drop
the mint
every time the exact same way so i need
to be
completely uninvolved no human element
these two solenoids here
will clamp the mint above the bottle
like this in its resting position and
this wire is connected to the triggering
system
of the robot and i've got it currently
set to at the beginning on
frame one of the robot move these two
solenoids will
release the mint straight down into the
bottle hopefully
and what that'll do is just remove me
from the equation i don't have to worry
about my timing and triggering the robot
the same time it should happen
perfectly in sync every time and that
will allow us to get
very adventurous with our shots let's
give it a go okay i've programmed
a very short move to track one of the
mints down into the bottle just gonna
test this on an empty bottle first
see how close i am on the timing three
two one drop
oh straight in i do have to be slightly
careful with this dropping mechanism so
i've set it to open on frame zero and
then
20 frames later it closes again because
if you hold solenoids open too long they
can
they get really hot and potentially
damage themselves so it's going to be
in real time open for less than a second
in slow-mo i'll probably open for about
30 seconds
okay powering on the robot
setting robot too fast going to
position one
lovely stuff three two one drop
[Music]
one
[Music]
uh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
so this is a very experimental video i
thought it'd be really cool
to get a pov of a mint going straight
down the bottle hole
and i think to do that i want to combine
the robot with the probe lens
however in order to look vertically down
i'm going to need to change the
configuration of the camera because as
you can see
if i try and tilt all the way down
the camera will actually impinge on the
underside of that arm there
so i'm going to take the camera off and
use this plate which will allow me to
flip the way the camera is mounted to a
side mount
and then if i turn the camera like this
it will be able to look
vertically straight down so it's quite a
shift in setup but it should allow us to
get
a pretty interesting shot all right so i
think i'm going to program this move
in reverse so i'm going to find my
position 2.
coming in hot it's like the moon landing
let's see right down the hall it's going
to be an insane shot if i can get it
get in there oh straight in
love it in order to get stupidly
ambitious with this up and down movement
i've now got the dropper device
mounted on bars to the end of the probe
lens so we're now looking at a mint
about
a couple of millimeters away and as the
robot
descends at full speed it's gonna let go
of the mint and i'm gonna pull focus on
it all the way down to the bottle
okay let's go to position one
i've also programmed a move in reverse
to follow the flume upwards three
two one whoop that's a wetland
oh it comes into the light it's like a
space vehicle
jettisoning an old booster
it's just such a graceful shot
[Music]
so
oh the timing on this one it's just so
perfect
oh looks like it was it was like the
same distance away the entire time
wow it's like a tiny little it's like
i've got a small
drone and i'm just flying above this
plume of liquid oh that looks so weird
the fact that it's not actually getting
any closer to the camera it just looks
like a weird
cg effect i love that shot
what insane what insane angle on that
[Music]
woof
[Music]
just absolutely washing the lens
looks like something out of portal
this is the kind of stuff you could just
film it over and over again it'd be
completely different every time
three two one
well there we have it some very
mesmerizing looking footage i've never
seen that done from
those angles and i think the colored
foam was a nice touch i'm very excited
to use this again
there'll be a second channel video
coming soon about that
and finally big thanks to mio for
sponsoring that video
mio may be small but it packs a mighty
punch a cheeky squeeze of mio adds
a lot of flavor to your water or soda
soda water whatever you want to squeeze
it in
and one of my favorite things about it
you get all the flavor but with zero
sugar and zero calories
if you want to give me a try there's a
link in the description thank you very
much for watching make sure you
subscribe
and i'll see you in the next one goodbye